[Música]
cierra los ojos por un momento y piensen
en una decisión que han tomado a lo
largo de sus vidas que los ha traído
estar en el momento donde se encuentran
ahora
háblanos a lo largo de mi vida he tomado
unas ciertas decisiones que me han
traído de estar el día de hoy dándoles
una conferencia en textil hace un año
decidí irme al otro lado del mundo hacer
voluntariado como maestra de inglés al
estar ahí me di cuenta que en indonesia
existe un severo problema de cáncer de
piel porque la gente no tiene conciencia
de lo importante que es el bloqueador
solar cuando apresan méxico iba
caminando por los pasillos de mi
universidad y me encontré con un póster
de un concurso en este concurso lo que
tenías que hacer era desarrollar una
idea que tuviera un impacto social en
nuestro país y si ganabas te ibas a
emitir a desarrollarlos
después de mis experiencias yo decidí
desarrollar un bloqueador solar
inteligente que ayudará a los niños a
crear conciencia sobre la importancia
del bloqueador solar y así bajar el
cáncer de piel de nuestro país que creen
que me fui a emitir y al está ella me di
cuenta que mi producto no era viable
falle bueno eso es lo que todos
hubiéramos creído pero por el contrario
porque estar ahí conocí a unas personas
que estaban interesadas en las
tecnologías más actuales del momento
cosas como inteligencia artificial o
machine learning yo me quedé apasionada
y hacer parte de esto cuando regrese a
méxico dije no me puedo quedar con los
brazos cruzados tengo que hacer algo al
respecto me tengo que involucrar es ahí
cuando decidí empezar a tomar clases de
programación a la par de eso empecé a
leer libros sobre inteligencia
artificial a ir a conferencias a
platicar con personas me metí mucho en
el tema después de esto aplique a un
inter 70 la vida para trabajar en una
start-up que estuviera usando
inteligencia artificial
pues un tema un poco extraño para una
niña que estudia mercadotecnia en el tec
no lo creen bueno
hoy vengo a compartir con ustedes un
concepto creado por mí este concepto se
llama rock & lounge y rock & long jing
es cuando las cosas despegan cuando las
cosas empiezan a pasar cuando una cosa
te empieza a llevar a la otra y a la
otra y a la otra y tú no sabes dónde vas
a llegar pero definitivamente las cosas
están pasando todas estas experiencias
personales que les acabo de compartir
son parte de mi proceso de rock & lounge
y proceso y es por eso que rock & lounge
inn es un término tan poderoso porque
habla del proceso nadie en esta vida
habla del proceso todo siempre se paran
y hablan de su historia de éxito al
final del camino y qué pasa con todo lo
de en medio cuando las cosas están
pasando cuando las cosas son imperfectas
es por eso que rock & lansing es tan
poderoso
hoy quiero invitarlos a pasar por unos
cuantos minutos a mi nave espacial mi
nave espacial se llama inteligencia
artificial para mortales como tú y yo
pero para que pueda pasar a mi nave
espacial
hay una regla y es muy importante que la
sigan existen unas palabras que se
llaman bos words 2 bolt son estas
palabras suenan difíciles que suenan
complicadas que suenan importantes más
que nada y la tecnología está ahí llena
de estas voces words quiero que traten a
estas voces words como si fuera
cualquier otra palabra como si fuera
silla como si fuera manzana y de esta
forma todos vamos a poder entender las
cosas de una forma mucho más clara
la primera volver de la noche data
tratáis simplemente información
información que constantemente estamos
generando data es los likes en instagram
las búsquedas en google las compras en
ambas son nuestra ubicación para
dejarles un concepto muy claro si tú
tuvieras en tu casa 10 dividís eso sería
edad porque cada uno de estos dividís
tiene un título un director una duración
un año en que fue creada
big bad beat gratis simplemente el
almacenamiento en grandes cantidades de
esta información
millones de likes en instagram millones
de búsquedas en google millones de
compras en amazon y netflix es big that
millones de películas con millones de
títulos millones de duraciones y más que
nada millones y millones de usuarios
algoritmo algoritmos simplemente es una
instrucción paso a paso de lo que tú
tienes que hacer para lograr un
resultado es como si quieres hacer un
pastel de chocolate algoritmo es poner
huevos harina chocolate lo revuelves lo
metes al horno lo sacas pastel de
chocolate
un algoritmo a tener en netflix es como
te recomiendo una película según tus
gustos
machine learning es el proceso por el
cual una computadora aprende sin que
nosotros lo programamos más elearning es
cuando aprende por experiencia es como
un niño chiquito que toca una estufa por
primera vez y se quema la mano y sabe
que no tiene que volver a tocarla
netflix usa machine learning cuando te
recomiendo la báscula tú le picas la
empiezas no te gusta y la quitas y de
esa forma sabe que ya no te la tiene que
volver a recomendarlo
inteligencia artificial antes de darles
mi definición les voy a dar un ejemplo
tan claro que estoy segura que se lo van
a llevar para toda su vida
imagínate que eres dueño de una
heladería en tu heladería hay nueve
sabores y tú te has dado cuenta que
estos nueve sabores no se venden de la
misma forma y lo que tú tienes que hacer
es decidir qué sabores y cuánto de cada
uno de estos sabores vas a poner para
tener máximas ventas y mínimos
desperdicios ahora imagínate que eres
dueño de una cadena de 2700 heladerías
en toda américa latina y lo que tienes
que hacer es exactamente lo mismo
decidir en cada una de tus heladerías de
helados y cuánto de cada uno vas a poder
imagínate la cantidad de variables que
están en esta decisión cosas como el
clima hace calor hace frío el perfil de
tus personas que viven cerca son adultos
son niños prefieren helados
tradicionales helados en tendencia o
cosas temporales que a nadie se le
ocurren como
son estudiantes los que viven cerca y
hay época de exámenes y prefieren
chocolate para concentrarse o es un
puente y las niñas prefieren el lado
frutal para estar en muy muy buena forma
la inteligencia artificial ayuda a tomar
esta decisión de una forma rápida
sencilla y eficaz porque a un ser humano
le tomaría muchísimo tiempo y esfuerzo
tomar todas estas decisiones todas estas
variables y hacer que funcione
entonces inteligencia artificial es
simplemente darle la oportunidad a una
computadora de pensar como si tuviera un
cerebro humano tú le das todos los
ejemplos para que esté puedes tomar
decisiones
así como los seres humanos los
alimentamos de comida la inteligencia
artificial se alimenta de datos y por
qué es importante eso hoy bueno según un
estudio de ibm el 90% de los datos que
existen hoy en día han sido creados
solamente desde 2016 y esto es
exponencial cada año se duplica los
datos y se duplican imagínense el poder
que tiene esto a un año a 5 a 10 y lo
que pasa es que con más datos las
decisiones de la inteligencia artificial
son más exactas entonces esto es muy
poderoso
después de tanto contexto me estoy
imaginando que están preguntándose y por
qué me viene hablar a mí aquí de esto ya
mí que me importa y porque aquí bueno
prende las luces por favor
quiero hacerles una pregunta alguien de
aquí es o quiere ser abogado levante la
mano
financiero
contador publicista artista director de
cine bueno a todos y cada uno de ustedes
la inteligencia artificial les importa
porque se va a convertir en su compañero
de trabajo
[Música]
existe una idea errónea de lo que es la
inteligencia artificial esta idea de un
robot malvado que primero nos ha quitar
todos nuestros trabajos y después va a
acabar por matar a todos los seres
humanos de la faz de la tierra esto fue
creado por las películas de ciencia
ficción y no es cierto por el contrario
la inteligencia artificial y los humanos
hacemos un gran equipo los humanos vamos
a poder seguir haciendo la parte
emocional la parte sentimental la parte
de juicio mientras que la inteligencia
artificial va a ser todos estos procesos
tediosos largos repetitivos y va a poder
poder tener resultados de manera mucho
más exacta fácil y acertada y de esta
forma inteligencia artificial más seres
humanos vamos a poder resolver problemas
mucho más complejos y lo mejor de todo
es que esto nos va a brindar la
oportunidad de hacer lo que mejor
sabemos hacer ser humanos
todos ustedes usan inteligencia
artificial todos los días y a lo mejor
ni siquiera lo saben alguien lea spotify
ha hecho un playlist específicamente
para ustedes inteligencia artificial
alguien usa weiss para llegar a los
lugares de manera fácil y rápida
inteligencia artificial alguien está
describiendo un mail en gmail y justo la
palabra que están pensando les aparece
inteligencia artificial y cosas un poco
más complicadas como un algoritmo que
detecta cáncer de manera mucho mucho más
exacta porque tiene millones de ejemplos
de lo que es cáncer y millones de
ejemplos de lo que no es cáncer o
inteligencia artificial que va a
resolver problemas legales porque
analiza todos los casos de la historia
de la humanidad y sus resultados y sabe
qué es lo que está bien y qué es lo que
está mal o este ejemplo estoy segura que
todos lo han escuchado los coches
autónomos que se manejan solos y te van
a llevar llegar a tu destino de manera
fácil y sin que tú tengas que hacer nada
la inteligencia artificial es como un
bebé un bebé que estamos criando entre
todos la información que nosotros le
demos y los ejemplos que nosotros le
brindemos son las herramientas que está
va a tomar para tomar decisiones y
resolver problemas en un futuro está ahí
la gran responsabilidad que tenemos
todos nosotros la responsabilidad de dar
los ejemplos correctos para que tome las
decisiones correctas
pero qué significa correcto cuando es un
grupo tan pequeño de personas los que
están involucrados en la inteligencia
artificial es por eso que necesitamos
diversidad diversidad de género
diversidad de religión de opinión
política de situación económica para que
cada quien dé su punto de vista y así
creemos una inteligencia y un futuro sin
sesgos
y quiero invitarlos a que vayan beyond
borders que es la cabeza que la
tecnología es para hombres primero que
nada que se quiten de la cabeza que la
tecnología es difícil es tediosa es
aburrida que la tecnología es para nerds
por favor que se quiten de la cabeza que
la tecnología no les importa porque como
les acabo de decir la inteligencia
artificial le importa a todas las
personas que están aquí presentes
y por último quiero invitarlos a que
tengan su propio rock & lounge cada uno
de ustedes sea en el tema que sea que
tengan su propio rock & launching que
despeguen que encuentran un tema y se
apasionen después de esto que no tengan
miedo a estar en el proceso porque
honestamente yo me encuentro en el
proceso y no es algo malo y por último
que compartan todo que descubran porque
todo suma y si cada uno de nosotros
tenemos nuestro propio rock & ranging
vamos a tener un rock & launching como
sociedad gracias